can they hear that music my music is
great spooky season
is almost over but there's nothing scary
about this okay dietitian mia sen
is sharing some recipes healthy recipes
i should say
of halloween treats let's check it out
hey las vegas now halloween may look a
little different this year but that
doesn't mean we can't enjoy
a healthier haunted spread at home today
i have some fun ideas
starting with a sheet pan snack mix to a
large mixing bowl add your fiber rich
ingredients
i'm adding no added sugar dried fruit
and air popped popcorn
then add your protein ingredients i'm
adding roasted chickpeas
pepitas and the cinnamon almond protein
cookie bites by k's naturals
all the k's naturals products including
the breakfast cereals pretzels and chips
are packed with plant protein so they
can naturally help manage blood sugars
and keep you satisfied for longer
they're also gluten free
low in fat and come in delicious flavors
like dill pickle and white cheddar
you can find them on amazon or
ksnaturals.com where you can also use
code
30 for 30 off finally add your fun
ingredient like dark chocolate
give that a toss and serve on a sheet
pan for easy snacking
so next we have a better for you dessert
option for chocolate coconut lovers
three ingredient samoas to a mixing bowl
add one mashed banana and three quarter
cup of shredded coconut
mix until combined transfer to a baking
sheet make into donut shapes and bake
for 15 minutes at 350 degrees fahrenheit
next melt your chocolate i'm using
jojo's chocolate bites which are made
with 70
dark chocolate with added plant-based
protein and
0 to 2.5 grams of sugar in each bite the
ghost hawaiian variety made with coconut
and macadamia nuts is perfect for this
recipe but
it also comes in other delicious flavors
including the peanut butter delight and
raspberry dream
it's non-gmo vegan paleo and keto
friendly and free of gluten soy and
dairy
you can find them at sprouts on amazon
and jojo's chocolate dot com
so next i have a sweet treat for ice
cream lovers
nyx swedish style ice cream is the first
better for you ice cream that's actually
super creamy and delicious
and contains no added sugar it's also
keto friendly with 360 calories or less
per pint
set up a better for you ice cream bar
with nutritious toppings like fruit
nuts seeds and dark chocolate for a fun
and delicious
halloween at home you can find nyx at
albertsons or order for fast delivery at
nyx.com
so finally we have a dietitian approved
option to hand out this halloween
that's it no added sugar fruit bars are
made with one key ingredient
whole fruit so they can help satisfy
sweet cravings while providing the
benefits of whole fruit nutrition
like fiber vitamins minerals and
antioxidants the bars make for a
convenient
grab-and-go snack or halloween candy
spot these plant-based snacks are also
non-gmo
vegan gluten-free and free of the top
major food allergens
you can find them at thatsitfruit.com
and on amazon
i hope you enjoyed these healthier
halloween tips and recipes you can find
them at my website nutritionbymia.com
and nutritionbymia on instagram where i
also share meal ideas and healthy
recipes daily